إذا كنت تعتقد أن الكركند يقضي عشاءًا سيئًا في
الغليان ، انتظر حتى
ترى الحرارة التي يأخذها أثناء صيده في
مصيدة جراد البحر ،
فلدينا الآن منظر شامل ونعم
هذا طائر مائي في فلوريدا ،
وضع الباحثون في مجال الحياة البرية كاميرا
داخل سرطان البحر  الفخاخ وشاهدت
صراعًا بين الحياة والموت مع
جراد البحر الأخطبوط مقابل الأخطبوط الذي ربح
الثور جيدًا بالإضافة إلى واحد في ذلك ،
قام الأخطبوط بشل جراد البحر ، وقاموا
بحقن تلك العصائر الهضمية
فيه
ثم قاموا بإفراغه مثل
مساعد باحث مساعد كيسي.
يقول بتلر إنهم عرفوا أن الكركند
يموت في الفخاخ لكنهم لم يعرفوا كيف
يرون الآن كيف أن الحيوانات المفترسة تحب
هجوم الأسماك الزناد وأن الكركند يحاول
شن دفاع جماعي يلوح
بقرون الاستشعار تلك الشائكة والصغيرة هي شكل دفاعها حتى لو غطس قمران  رأسه
داخل الفخ بعد أن
يستمر الوحش في وضع رأسه لأسفل
في قفصه ،
نعم ، هذا واحد دعني أخبرك أنني
لم أكن أكره  عندما كنت أراجع
هذا الفيديو وفجأة انبثق
رأس طائر وتخيل أنه محاصر
عندما تجول سمكة قرش
في كبير الخدم يقول أن سمكة القرش بدت
مرتعبة ليجد نفسها في الفخ
ولم تأكل أي سرطان البحر
[الموسيقى]
تمكنت من  تجد طريقها للخروج من الكركند
يجب أن تشعر وكأن لديها هدفًا على
ظهورها ، كيف تريد أن تكون
صورة على مريلة
يتم غليها ، قم
بلفها على الفور ، وقم
بلف أذيالها ومخالبها ، وهي تأخذ قصفًا
والآن نكتشف  إنهم يخاطرون بأن يكونوا
عشاء مخلوق آخر بينما ينتظرون
أن يصبحوا جني العشاء لدينا في
معظم
cnn نيويورك